commission what are we saying how have
you structured that so we originally we
had a sort of flat fee structure with
basically the more responsibility they
have in as a delivery person the higher
commission they get per placement we had
a lot of feedback over like last summer
and stuff around like some of the
delivery people who are maybe a bit
unhappy but the problem is that there
was a huge discrepancy between the
delivery guys and the 360 guys and you
know we had a fair few of them who had
only been recruitment for you know like
a couple of years two three years
earning sort of you know 150 200 Grand a
year and because there's such a a
difference between the two teams that
was basically just like pissing them off
a little bit so we did a big like deep
dive into it and changed the model a
little bit to bring the two commissions
a bit more in line basically split the
value of the deals